all right uh let's talk about Jeremy
Renner the Marvel star shared an update
on his recovery and we're so happy he is
recovering the Hawkeye actor was of
course was badly injured and hurt on New
Year's Day when he was injured by a
seven ton snow machine at his Nevada
home Renner is recovering and he wrote
on social media quote these broken plus
these 30 plus broken bones will mend
grow stronger just like the love and
bond with family and friend deepens
Marvel co-star Chris Evans responded
that's one tough leap yeah you all can
figure out what he's trying to say yeah
has anyone even checked on the snow cat
Runner wrote back isn't that funny yeah
love you brother I did check on the snow
cat she needs fuel he's making a joke
but when you think of seven tons that
you were still here to tell the time
it's amazing yes well I mean 30 plus
bones it actually made me look up how
many bones are in the human body
206. give or take yeah so I know we keep
you know we're so excited he's doing
well and everybody wants to see him
return to the screen but I'm just happy
he's alive me too because because as
John Tower our senior broadcast producer
pointed out to me a Toyota Corolla
weighs 3 000 pounds oh wow so the thing
that he that fell on him were that you
know three thousand pounds is a Toyota
Corolla I know you could pick that up
uh Jeremy Renner love you can't wait to
see you back in full action